now passengers on board the Grand
Princess now docked at a port in
Auckland disembarking after being
quarantined on the vessel off the coast
of California Teresa Duncan Johnson is
one of those passengers she and her
husband John were on an anniversary trip
before they were stranded at sea for
days she is disembarking at this very
moment and joins us now by phone
Teresa good morning good morning Sandra
how are you I'm doing fine thank you and
thank you for calling in we're glad you
you've been able to to return now what
happens to you and your husband now
well this morning when we woke up where
we see the letter from Princess under
our door with our tags telling us that
we need to be prepared to disembark the
letter basically said that we needed to
have our luggage out no later than 7:00
a.m. Pacific time so we had everything
basically packed already got up and got
ready now we're just waiting we're
waiting to hear the captain come on and
tell us that they're beginning the
process we also had heard yesterday that
they had called some passengers that
ended up having you come back to the
cabin so we're hoping for a better
situation today we don't know if we'll
be walking out the door in a few minutes
or if we'll be sitting here for the next
several hours it's just kind of a
standby so what have you been told about
where exactly you'll go next well we
live in Georgia so we are expecting to
board a military transport to Dobbins
Air Force Base there in Marietta Georgia
which north of Atlanta what was the
quarantine process for for you and your
husband like when you had to be confined
to your cabin on your anniversary trip
knowing that this virus was on board and
that there were affected passengers well
I think the good news for us is that we
were able to get off this get off the
ship go and see Hawaii and this we
didn't find out about until Wednesday
before we were supposed to arrive back
on Saturday
so we knew we weren't going to be back
on Saturday anyway Thursday is when they
did quarantine us to our cabin and we
did basically what we would do at home
we watch the news
we were fox news fans and we watch the
news and we read and watched movies they
actually added about 300 movies to our
TV channel so we had things entertain us
and Princess gave us a lot of activities
to do puzzles and little crafts they
were trying to keep give us things to
keep us busy so for the most part you
know we were just basically in our room
when we didn't get off the ship on
Saturday and we didn't know when we were
going to be able to be brought back into
town to get off during body level does
go up a little bit and you wonder if
you're going to be another you know 14
days sitting out middle of the ocean
somewhere but we were really happy when
we found out we were going to get the
port yesterday well another couple on
board did not handle it it sounds quite
so well as you and they did not approve
of the handling of the princess cruise
lines dealing with this accusing them of
gross negligence they're suing them for
a million dollars that says that they
knowingly that the ship was infected
from two previous passengers who came
down with the symptoms of CO vid 19 and
had 62 passengers on board do you plan
on to take plan on taking any legal
action against the cruise line I do not
I think that's unfortunate that they
have come to that conclusion I guess
everybody has to make their own choice
with that but for me and my husband we
felt like that princess has gone above
and beyond what they could do in this
situation we had to fill out a
questionnaire when we were getting on
board its whether we had been in the
areas in China basically at the time
that had been infected we did get on the
ship on the 21st of February and as I
understand it the people who came down
sick we're not identified until sometime
after we're already on board I don't
think that's Prince this fall they made
action and started doing things
you know for the benefit of the
passenger during the time that that was
announced and they have done a lot of
things for us they gave us a hundred
percent of this cruise and all of our
travel expenses and everything we've
purchased on board they've comped all
that back to us husband giving us future
cruise that 100% paid I mean I feel very
fortunate they have done so much yeah
and I would have expected because we did
get to make this trip well it's a very
it domestic you have everything it's
admirable and we're thankful that you
and your husband are doing ok happy
Anniversary to you glad you were able to
get a portion of your vacation in and
thank you for calling in Theresa it was
a pleasure speaking with you thank you
for that we'd love to follow up with you
so come back on soon thank you
thank you